now listen
i'm so sorry but um
my show ain't ready
well close to 24 hours before she was
set to kick off her las vegas residency
adele postponing all of her dates at
caesar's palace good evening i'm denise
valdez and i'm brian loftis adele had
rehearsed in las vegas this week but
just couldn't make it happen many fans
are disappointed especially those who
just flew into town today sasha loftis
heard from one woman tonight hey sasha
hey brian and denise yes this was just
really a huge blow for the thousands who
were set to see adele here in las vegas
tomorrow night the woman i spoke with
this evening says she heard the news
when she was already on a flight halfway
here
i'm really really sorry in an emotional
message adele announced to the world
thursday she's postponing her residency
i got it and i'm sorry it's a last
minute the news came just over 24 hours
before her first show at caesars palace
meaning many had already made plants
including jana roo who traveled here
from portland i was mid flight when she
canceled it was obviously too late to
turn around so she's still spending the
weekend on the strip not super happy
about it but you know is it really that
unexpected adele said her team tried
everything they could to move forward
but claims delivery delays and covert
related curve balls made it impossible
half my crew half my team are down with
kobe they still are and it's been
impossible to finish the show caesars
released this statement saying the hotel
and casino is confident the show she
eventually unveils will be extraordinary
still many today are in a tough spot
it's tough and you know obviously you
paid a lot of money to get here but rue
hopes fans can make the best of things
and hope for better options in the
future there are lots of things that
aren't in our control
now janice said she did pay to get kova
testing at caesar's palace ahead of the
show and they did refund her for that
now as for those dates those residency
dates adele said in that message earlier
today that all new or all residency
dates rather would be rescheduled no
word on when that will happen yet and no
word on whether anyone was refunded for
the show tomorrow night reporting live
tonight sacha loftis live local now